[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm dr. Justin Jackson professor
of English at Hillsdale College in this
course we'll be covering the book of
Genesis and some of the most famous
stories that that most people know and
we'll be keeping an eye on particular
literary qualities of the text itself
the first story that we'll be covering
will be the creation of Adam and Eve and
their consequent expulsion from the
Garden of Eden before we begin in the
narrative proper I think it's important
to understand kind of the various
relationships that we'll see not just in
the opening story of Genesis but in many
ways these relationships that will come
to dominate throughout the entire
narrative the first relationship is the
relationship between God and creation
after God and creation we know that
there's a clear relationship between God
and human beings a third relationship is
the relationship between human to human
contact and finally one that we won't
focus on too much throughout the text
but it's all throughout Leviticus and
even here early on in Genesis is the
relationship between human beings and
creation and I think what's most
fascinating when we start looking at
this kind of four-part relationship is
we want to ask we want to start to ask
about what is the intersection between
the relationship between God and human
beings and human beings and human beings
more to the point I want to ask is what
is the way in which perhaps the face of
God shows up there in the human to human
relationship how does the human human
human to human relationship offer us up
kind of an eruption an interruption of
that divine in human relationship as
well so let's turn to Genesis in the
creation of Adam and Eve we're told in
Genesis chapter 126 that God has made
man in His image and by his likeness has
he made him and this is a really
important distinction because man is
unlike anything else in creation in some
ways man is the mediator it's kind of
this it's standing there at this central
position between heaven that is to say
the divine and earth
that is to say the material creation
between the animals in some ways we see
the man standing right between is in
some way just kind of he sits there with
these divine qualities and
simultaneously these these very earthly
qualities and it's the tension between
the two the tension between the earthly
and the divine that comes to it comes to
define man's interaction with other
humans and the divine throughout the
book in Genesis chapter two verse five
on the day the Lord God made earth and
heavens no shrub of the field being yet
on the earth and no planted the field
yet sprouted for the Lord God had not
caused rain to fall on the earth there
was no human to till the soil and
wetness would well from the earth to
water all the surface of the soil then
God fashioned the human humus from soil
and blew into his nostrils the breath of
life and the human became a living
creature now I'm sure this translation
sounds a little odd to you humus from
the soil this is Robert alters
translation of Genesis and he's trying
to he's trying to depict for us in
English the word played it's there in in
Hebrew Adam just means the human being
and the human being the word play there
it was taken from Adam ah which means
from the soil God's taking this human
being from the soil but note he is into
the human once God blows into his
nostrils you see the breath of God you
see something of the divine coming down
to the human that that that soil the
soil and the divine coming together in
this one figure here it's really a thing
of beauty you see this this kind of a
majestic creature unlike the other ones
thus far we go down a little bit long it
would go a little bit more and we see
that the that the human has somewhat of
a project here and the Lord God took the
human and set him down in the Garden of
Eden to till it and watch it - till it
means a another way to translate it is
to serve it a baaad in and
and
- watch it Samar means it's closer to
something like to guard and protect it
so we're there to serve it to guard it
and protect it there's this keepers of
this creation and there's something of
an irony here by the time we get to the
end of Genesis chapter 3 what you'll see
is after the transgression everything
gets subverted rather than our guarding
and protecting the garden God has to
send the cherubim with the flaming sword
- in fact protect it from us the
original transgression is going to throw
a wrench into the system here of what
this divine human relationship looks
like and the Lord God commanded the
human saying from every fruit of the
garden you made sure they eat but from
the tree of knowledge good and evil you
shall not eat from the day you eat from
it you are doomed to die so now here we
get the this first commandment this
first prohibition something about this
tree of knowledge of good and evil and
we'll get there a little more in depth
when we go to chapter 3 but we are not
to eat of it we are doomed to die and we
have to ask well how do we understand
who you are doomed to die usually in
class when when when I ask how do you
understand this most students will
respond oh I have always imagined they
think if you heard that command you
would think as soon as you eat that
fruit you die we'll see something else
gets played out a little bit more in the
text and I think the most startling
statement and the entirety of these
opening chapters of the first three
chapters of Genesis comes now here in
verse 18 and the Lord God said it is not
good for the human to be alone I shall
make him a sustainer beside him for the
first time if you go back to Genesis
chapter 1 God repeatedly says and it was
good and it was good and it was good
every act of creation is good all things
are good in this narrative but now we
are going to get a key insight with
regards to the human and really what it
means to be a human because for the
first time we are told that something is
not good and it is not good that man as
a
this comes to help us understand our
place in the cosmos is this mediator
between the earthly and the heavenly we
also know that we aren't these
autonomous beings answerable to no one
we would like to say we're only
answerable to God but even here we
understand there is something about what
it means to be the human here that being
in isolation is wholly unacceptable and
so what does God do
he starts fashioning animals the Lord
fashioned from the soil each beast of
the field and each fowl of the heavens
and brought each to the human to see
what he would call it whatever the human
called a living creature that was its
name so there are two things going on
here one he's creating the animals
precisely as he creates as he creates
the human that is to say from the soil
save he doesn't breathe into it that's
part 1 part 2 and I want to go back to
man being made in the image and likeness
of God notice what he does here man now
is using his words to name these animals
and not only that but there is something
of the divine human relationship here
which then says and God would would
abide by whatever the man calls these
animals so now man is almost as taking
part in this divine project he is using
his words as God uses his words at
creation man is now participating with
the divine in this act of creation by
naming these animals but of course where
we're told after all of this there was
no sustainer found for the human in
these animals verse 21 and the Lord God
cast a deep slumber on the human and he
slept and he took one of his ribs and
closed over the flesh where it had been
and the Lord God built the rib he had
taken from the human into a woman and he
brought her to the human and the human
said this one at last bone of my bones
and flesh of my flesh this one shall be
called woman for for man was this one
taken it's this beautiful moment because
what we see here with regards to
humankind's
notion of personhood is that it's a
corporate personhood is that to
understand what it means to be a human
person isn't simply to be a unique
individual surrounded by all these other
unique individuals made in the same way
but rather we are in a sense incomplete
with we can't even name who we are we
have no identity if we are not in a
relationship to another human person in
fact look at the look at the the poem
that Adam offers to us this one at last
bone of my bones and flesh of my flesh
notice he names this one precisely in
the way in which he's going to name the
animals this one shall be called woman
the Hebrew he shall also a word that's
used for wife this one shall be called
woman Esau and now notice what he does
for from man
each was this one taken it's a beautiful
moment because now what you see is in
the act of naming this other human being
across from him only then can he
actually name himself as a separate
identity because it's really not a
separate identity they're bound to one
another the very notion of personhood
here is is found here in this
relationship from Esau only once that's
named can I actually now have an
understanding of myself and so this
begins to stake out what do the human to
the human relationship is and then what
we will see
come chapter 3 is is as a fall as a
disruption is a rupture of this human to
human relationship and it turns out
their rupture and this human to human
relationship where she is to be a
sustainer to him he has to find his own
personhood there in yah what we'll find
here is it's also a disruption in the
divine and human relationship so now we
move into the opening moments of the
transgression now the serpent was most
cunning of all the beasts of the field
that the Lord God had made and he said
to the woman though God said you shall
not eat from any tree of the garden and
the woman said to the serpent from the
fruit of the gardens trees we may eat
but from the fruit of the tree in the
midst of the garden God has said you
shall not eat from it and you shall not
touch it
lest you die and the serpent said to the
woman you shall not be doomed to die for
God knows that on the day you eat of it
your eyes will be open and you will
become as God's knowing good and evil
and the woman saw that the tree was good
for eating and that it was lust to the
eyes and the tree was lovely to look at
and she took of its fruit and ate and
she also gave to her a man and he ate
and the eyes of the two were opened and
they knew they were naked and they so
fig leaves and made themselves loin
cloths so let's go through some of these
details and and try to read them afresh
to read them anew oftentimes we can get
stuck in that same theological narrative
and not start asking these questions of
this of this of this text so let's just
begin first and foremost with the
narrative that we know also well God
gave Adam and Eve a commandment they're
prideful desire to become like gods as
it precisely would allows them to be
tempted by the serpent and giving in to
this temptation they break a commandment
of God and thus break their relationship
with the divine and as a consequence of
this god of course escorts them out of
the garden and in some ways we read this
as a just response they had a
commandment they broke the commandment
they broke their relationship with the
divine and now of course they have to
live their life quite differently now in
this world so let's keep that in the
back of our mind but now I want us to
start asking things anew because there
are all sorts of questions we can have
here the first question we can ask is
about this tree of knowledge of good and
evil
what is this tree what is this knowledge
of good and evil the first thing I think
we have to assert is that the tree of
knowledge and good and evil because God
made it it is there for good we were
told that everything God makes in this
garden is in fact good so that means
this tree in and of itself is not evil
there is a knowledge there and the tree
is good though they have been commanded
do not eat of it and so now we can ask
well why would God not allow them to eat
of it and now let's go back to where we
were previously
he made them in the divine image and
likeness he breathed himself into them
they are these mediators of the earthly
in the heavenly and yet they're told you
shall not have this knowledge of good
and evil you shall not be like gods Adam
gets to name the animals and God abides
by his naming this seems very confusing
is this not part of the project that
they should become like gods we have all
sorts of clues and the text that this
may in fact be the case and so the
question the objections often raised to
this story is why would God create
something good that is the knowledge of
good and evil and then tell them no and
tell them no in perpetuity so often we
focus on just the knowledge of evil
because of the shame they feel but what
about the good what about the knowledge
of good would their knowledge of God not
even be heightened at this moment if
they ate of it since God is the very
source of good I think this is maybe
what we start to come to understand is
that there is a double source of
knowledge here it is a knowledge of good
and evil in this text the evil is that
consciousness of transgression and that
consciousness of shame but the shame
comes from the very moment they eat of
that tree and are exposed even more to
that goodness it's a double exposure
here the more they're exposed to the
good the more shame they're going to
feel each piece of that knowledge feeds
off of one another so now let's go back
and look from from through some of these
details the serpent says though God said
you shall not eat from any tree of the
garden notice that Eve here interrupts
him immediately she says from the fruit
of the gardens trees we may eat but from
the fruit of the tree in the midst of
the garden God has said you shall not
eat from it and you shall not touch it
notice she expands the command here
you shall not touch it where did she get
this command
is she have a great desire for this tree
which by the way is lust to the eyes
it's beautiful and of course it's
beautiful God has made this tree it is
good it has a knowledge of the good and
of the evil of course it's beautiful
is this what's tempting her she doesn't
want to touch it because the moment she
touches that fruit and takes it and she
doesn't die does that mean surely we can
now eat of it because she added this
commandment to this to the previous
commandment to give herself an excuse to
go ahead and eat this or perhaps his
other commentaries have asked is this
the command that Adam gave to her to
protect her did Adam say Eve don't eat
of the fruit don't even touch it
is she simply repeating what Adam has
said so there's an expansion here and
notice the serpent this is why he's so
cunning because notice there are two
things going on here he tells a lie and
he tells the truth simultaneously you
shall not be doomed to die and we know
this is untrue for God knows that it on
the day you eat of it your eyes will be
open and you will become let as God's
knowing good and evil
notice the conflation here you're not
doomed to die because if you become like
God knowing good and evil therefore you
shall be immortal but there are two
trees the tree of knowledge of good and
evil in the Tree of Life
so here the the serpent is quite cunning
because he tells the truth as well he
says you will become like God's knowing
good and evil
and they heard the sound of the Lord God
walking about in the garden in the
evening breeze and the human and his
woman hid from the Lord God in the midst
of the trees of the garden and the Lord
God called to the human and said to him
where are you what a beautiful question
where are you I mean this is kind of
this existential question for Adam now
just think about it he's hiding from his
creator the one to whom he was called to
be in relationship he's now hiding from
him he won't read there isn't a respond
here
and he said I heard your sound in the
garden and I was afraid for I
naked and I hid and he said who told you
that you were naked from the tree I
commanded you not to eat have you eaten
notice these questions and these
questions are are very interesting
precisely because of their questions
this omniscient God creator of heaven
and earth and of all things visible and
invisible does not know where Adam and
Eve are what do we make of these
questions in some ways we can look back
to the various traditions both rabbinic
and Christian and they understand these
questions in a very precise way and this
is God calling Adam and Eve to
repentance he's asking Adam to admit
what he is done look the narrative here
let's just boil it down to some put
something simple there are Commandments
in this case there's one command one is
to keep it to stay in relationship to
the divine in fact is a blessing to to
observe the commandments why because
they are divine given the commandments
come from the divine and we meet those
commands and our earthly in in spiritual
way then we are that we are that proper
mediator follow the commandments if you
don't follow the commandments repent
repent simply turn back to God and say
I'm sorry God I did not follow the
commandments and then of course you'll
be asked to follow the commandments it's
a really simple narrative that we can
see all throughout these biblical texts
and in particular here if we understand
this is part of a penitential narrative
this original expulsion that already has
built into it a commandment and a desire
from God who is long-suffering merciful
and abounding in love as exodus tells us
he desires he desires the transgressor
to turn and return to God and following
the commandments so he gives them the
ability to repent to admit what they've
done and he said who told you that you
were naked from the tree the I command
you not to eat you of eaten and the
human said here's this chance to repent
the woman whom you gave by me she gave
me from the tree and I ate
now all of a sudden I think we can see
what's going on here if we're talking
about the intersection of the divine and
human relationship combined with the
human and human relationship then what
we see here is a is a rupture of both
simultaneously Adam who has his life who
names himself only after this woman
who's taken from him buries his very
self who gives him a sense of personhood
this sustainer beside him notice what
he's willing to do he cuts her off in
his language is perfect the woman whom
you gave to me in in a double sense he's
passing off this responsibility to his
wife and now to God so we see a
simultaneous disruption of the divine
relationship and the human relationship
here cutting himself off for both rather
than saying I failed Lord rather than
taking responsibility for his wife even
if she is the one who gave him the fruit
rather than saying I didn't teach her
well enough I wasn't watching her
closely rather than doing anything to
try to sustain his sustainer he cuts her
off and cuts God off and the Lord God
said to the woman what is this you have
done and the woman said the serpent
beguiled me and I ate notice what she
does here passes blame off to the
serpent she doesn't even mention that
she gave the fruit to Adam in he ate she
doesn't even mention this and maybe we
can even ask what why are they so
unrepentant here
why won't they turn back and I think a
lot of it has to go we have to go back
and say and look at it I want to say the
prophecy that God gives to the humans
it's a commandment and a prophetic
uttering do not eat from the tree of
knowledge of good and evil from the day
you eat of it surely you're a doomed to
die how do they understand that doomed
to die can they repent what if that
repentance and they name yes in fact
Lord we ate from it what if they
understand that that now here comes
death just ask yourself how did you
understand that first commandment
did you understand it as an immediate
death that's been promised to them not
as something that's eventual not as
something that cuts them off from the
The Tree of Life but something that is
immediate is it their fear of death that
allows them that causes them not to
repent is that what we're seeing here
and of course afterwards we get to see
we get to see the effects of all of this
the change and Adams relationship to
creation how he has to work by the sweat
of his brow the birth pangs for Eve and
the Lord God made skin coats for the
human and his woman and he clothed them
and the Lord God said now that the human
has become like one of us knowing good
and evil
he may reach out and take as well from
the tree of life and live forever and
the Lord God sent from the Garden of
Eden to till the soil from which he had
been taken I want us to just take a look
now that the human has become like one
of us knowing good and evil he may reach
out and take as well from the tree of
life and live forever and this is
poignant let's go back to our usual
reading of this how do we understand
this usually if we take if we take Adam
and Eve's original transgression as one
of Pride this this innate desire there's
overwhelming desire to become like gods
then we see in what God offers to us
here is he has some sense of a rivalry
between Adam and Eve but he does not
want them to become gods he did now that
they know all of this we can't let them
live forever or they will be like one of
us does he fear a rivalry I would say we
can look at other details and perhaps
give us another understanding here again
with the notion of repentance with the
notion that God is is long-suffering and
abounding and love rather than some
judgment for their pride what if this
isn't a God who is merciful and
compassionate in his in his justice so
let's just go back a little bit and ask
a couple of questions what is the state
that Adam and Eve are now in with
regards to their relationship to the
divine
they stand in front of him naked and
ashamed whereas before they were naked
and did not know it because they've had
this double knowledge they've
transgressed in our conscious of their
transgression and they are ashamed of it
and they're standing in the very
presence of the divine and by the way
they have become God's knowing good and
evil
let's not make let's not mistake this
they have become like gods knowing good
and evil and now God says let's cut them
off from the Tree of Life
lest they become immortal but now let's
just think of what their state is in
this knowledge now their state is one of
shame and now you can really start
thinking about justice and mercy would
not justice be God saying I told you not
to eat of the tree of knowledge and good
and evil and yet you've done so and so
now you shall just have the fruit of
your transgression here you shall now
live in this shame which you've brought
upon yourself and think about what this
means what they brought to the garden a
garden which is paradise they now would
live for an eternity in shame and the
presence of God and there is a specific
word for that and that is hell they
would have transformed this paradise
that God has given to them to become
these mediators that they become these
divine like creatures and they would
have turned it all and to help to grow
in their relationship and turn it all
into Health in fact we can go back and
even ask
then why I put the tree of knowledge of
good and evil in the garden oftentimes
you say because they needed to exercise
that that freewill they had they can't
love God and obey Him if there isn't a
freewill and let me just accept that but
let me go one better and say um um that
it is a good thing and that a certain
point they would have been able to eat
from it this is not a God who fears a
rivalry this is a God who created human
beings in His image and likeness is
going to watch them grow to fruition and
of this and would have let them eat from
the tree eventually and then we asked
eventually what would that take let me
let me just submit that at least the
first step in growing towards that
divine human relationship the first
event that would have
them access to the tree of knowledge and
good and evil would have been to abstain
from the nut tree of knowledge of good
and evil and listen to the commandment
of God had they done this had they
exercised that free will and following
the commandment of God that would have
opened the path to the knowledge of good
and evil for for them and to become like
gods
but to have a better understanding to
have grown in that relationship with the
divine and so when we look here now that
the human has become like one of us
knowing good and evil that let us not
let them take from the tree of life and
live forever
God is not afraid of a rivalry of his
creation he's not afraid that they've
become gods he set everything in place
so that they could become godlike I mean
really is a God who created mud he's
created soil and he's turned them into
gods is it God who has that sort of
enormous power really going to rival
these godlike creatures that he's
created from mud rather it was a
graciousness on the part of the divine
to say I am going to create creatures
who with their will can live and
participate in the divine life and
whereas at one point they had one
commandment to do so well now okay we
have the original transgression now they
have sixteen hundred and thirteen
Commandments to do so and those sixteen
hundred and thirteen Commandments should
be seen as a joy as another another
opportunity to exist in that divine and
human relationship so then what we see
here then cutting them off from the
Garden of Eden to put the cherubim at
that tree of life to cut them off from
immortality to become these godlike
creatures living in shame and perpetuity
rather than an act of justice it is an
act of mercy rather than letting them by
their own free will create a hell out of
a paradise which he's given to them he
has cut them off from that and is going
to now allow them to exist in
relationship to the divine in a
different manner and the rest of Genesis
is going to be a teasing out and through
through the hole to knock through the
holy brew Bible is going to be a
question of what
does that new relationship look like and
so next time we will pick up on this as
we take a look at the Abraham narrative
you
[Music]